[Music]
we all know that security is a critical
part of any IT infrastructure and a key
part of a Solutions Architect role is to
ensure that all resources residing on
the AWS cloud are securely protected you
need to ensure that resources can only
be reached by the end users or
applications that should be accessing
them for this you have to design and
control the security access to AWS so
that end users and applications do not
have more permissions than they need
along with this you have to enforce
strict password policies to make sure
there are no weak points of entry into
your cloud environment
fortunately AWS makes it easy to do all
of this and more how through the AWS
identity access management service that
enables you to securely control access
for AWS services and resources for your
users this lesson will cover all the
features available within the AWS
Identity and Access Management Service
so let's begin so what is I am well
identity an access management is the
service that enables you to securely
control user access to all your AWS
services and resources it's based around
the concept of user management that
you'll already be familiar with users
groups and permissions so here we're
just going to go through the key
features by them and then we'll cover
each of them in more depth so the first
thing is it gives you shared access to
your account it provides granular
permissions
it gives secure access to AWS resources
it can provide identity Federation and
if you're not sure what that is we'll
cover that identity information for
assurance which is crucial these days
with all the auditing that goes on its
PCI DSS compliant it allows you to set
up a password policy and also
multi-factor authentication
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here